sometimes you got to just let it [ __ ]
know and remind them for the you are so
they're too afraid to take advantage of
you Khloe Kardashian hits her breaking
point as Jordan woods sits down with
Jada pinkett-smith for her red Table
Talk interview my world got destroyed
while Jordan is doing press interviews
about it who though do you think you are
she can't call me to apologize not one
time she never called me one time after
the Tuesday when she admitted what she
did of course I'm sorry and apologetic
as much as I can be in on Sunday night's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians we finally see exactly what
went down in the Kardashian camp ahead
of Jordans interview with Jada following
the Tristan Thompson cheating scandal
things got ugly
leaving momager Kris Jenner speechless
after she admitted to Khloe
Jada reached out to her before the
sit-down you don't get it I know I was
trying to protect Khloe's heart yeah she
doesn't deserve this
either earlier in the episode Kim Kourt
and Chloe's besties at Malika took cocoa
to Palm Springs for a girls trip to lift
her spirits but it seemed to only make
things worse
this is so good whack that these [ __ ]
think they could go ahead and our men
mom they're gonna try to your man in a
second after several margaritas Chloe
called Tristan's buddy back in Cleveland
that's when we finally got to see at
this moment we've been waiting for all
season
Kristin you could hear me
[Music]
[Applause]
Chloe also addressed her controversial
tweets from March when she alleged
Jordan was the reason her family was not
together anymore I know I'm not the
reason that just didn't Chloe you're not
together even though Jordan played a
part I do feel bad if anyone would think
I was putting the sole blame on her cuz
that's not the truth and I only like to
speak my truth gnashing either side it's
just not cool for me we also got to see
several attempts on Tristan's part where
he tried contacting Chloe even sending
her flowers I'm like what is wrong with
you I'm not speaking to you yeah you're
the one who did this to me now why are
you torturing me all night long he was
like you're my soul mate and partner
soul my spirit my heart everything is
just shattered and et spoke with Koko
after part 1 of the finale aired last
week where she opened up about the drama
and keeping the peace
anybody I don't think there needs to be
negativity on anywhere I think it's just
a story that's being told but anybody
picking aside or you know condemning any
human I think this is a part of life I'm
not saying it wasn't it yeah
[Music]